bonsoir parce qu'elle sort et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur il sur
rtl france tout d'abord ces chiffres de
l'île de france
ils sont en accord avec donc les
modélisations pas de surprise c'est le
variant clairement qu'il prend pas il
faut agir plus fortement selon vous
priori c'est pas forcément le variant
qui est en cause mais peut-être le
relâchement de la population qui en a
marre ça fait un an qu on confine
couvre-feu on interdit aux fermes et
restaurants et je pense que c'est plus
un problème de ras-le-bol général et on
le voit bien dans la population bien ce
week-end sur paris les bords de seine
qui ont été évacués manu militari et je
pense que le problème du marion n'est
pas forcément le problème principal
vous comprenez justement cette
population qui en a ras-le-bol et encore
vous citiez l'ile-de-france mais enfin
il le français plutôt bien lotis par
rapport à d'autres départements le
déclin va être confiné à nouveau on se
pose la question pour les
alpes-maritimes
l'île de france y échappe en quelque
sorte c'est une bonne chose selon vous
je pense que c'est tout à fait
compréhensible pour les gens oui ça fait
un an qu'on va fêter le 16 mars le
premier confinement les gens n'ont plus
aucune activité hors sortir se promener
il ya plus de restaurants et une
activité culturelle du musée
même si d'un point de vue médical où on
serait pour renforcer les mesures
je comprends bien qu'au niveau humain ça
serait difficile
alors il ya la vaccination évidemment
tout le monde a les yeux rivés vers
cette campagne qui nous a accordé
beaucoup de surprises et de confusion en
tout cas encore cette semaine
clairement on a vu des médecins
généralistes très en colère ici même sur
rt france vous en faites partie
la colère ne retombe pas
dans votre secteur dans votre profession
tout à fait on est selon les propos du
gouvernement en phase d'accélération de
la vaccination est là les annonces de
dimanche soir de la direction générale
de la santé nous donner un vrai coup de
frein à la fois à la vaccination et à
l'élan de motivation des médecins
généralistes
juste pour permettre aux pharmaciens de
vacciner à partir du 15 mars
on bloque les commandes de vaccins pour
les médecins de ville qui s'était déjà
organisé pour vacciner je vous cache pas
que moi j'ai des plages de vaccination
de prévu on associe avec juin plage de
consultations vendredi qu'il obligé
d'annuler qu'on nous a déjà promené en
nous annonçant la vaccination des 50-64
ans puis les 50 75 ans les moins de 75
ans avec problèmes de santé les plus de
75 ans une succession d'annoncés de la
direction générale à santé tout se
contredisant les unes des autres et ça
nous donne énormément de travail à faire
et puis du jour au lendemain brutalement
à 22 heures à dimanche soir on nous dit
la semaine du 8 mars vous ne pourrez pas
commander et la phrase qui nous fait
vraiment du mal du tort c'est les jo
seront réservés aux officines
pharmaceutiques et ça c'est inacceptable
inadmissible je vous cache pas que nous
sommes en contact avec d'autres médecins
sur les réseaux sociaux et la plupart
n'ont même plus envie de continuer la
campagne vaccinale parce qu'elle serait
comment gérer ça parce que vous l'avez
dire vous vacciner vous aussi des
personnes à vis à risque atteint de
comorbidité ces gens là que vous deviez
vaccinez vous avaient annulé leur
rendez-vous vous avez eu quand même la
possibilité de les maintenir en accord
peut-être avec des formations je ne sais
pas alors avec les pharmaciens il n'y a
aucune possibilité de toute façon la
commande des nouvelles doses de vaccin
formellement bloqués moi j'ai encore la
possibilité de faire une série de
l'accession de 10 personnes parce que
j'ai un flacon
mais les les patients que nous avions
appelée et qu'on devait programmer la
scène suivante et ben on les rappelle
leur disant ne prévoyait rien et moi je
vais attendre d'avoir des doses de
vaccin pour appeler les gens donc tout
ça va faire que rallonger
on voit bien dans d'autres pays on voit
bien l'exemple d'israël on va bien à
l'exemple de l'ecosse de l'angleterre
les premiers résultats pour la
vaccination sont très encourageants si
on se retrouve décalé tout de quinze
jours trois semaines
juste pour obtenir des doses pouvoir
continuer à vacciner en médecine de
ville les gens ils ont confiance en leur
médecin traitant
quand m 5 septembre dijon vacciner les
patients ils vont suivre pour la plupart
on perd toute crédibilité quand on
commande auprès du pharmacien une dose
or il faut les commander du lundi au
mercredi
pour être livré la semaine d'après là ça
veut dire qu'on va commander la semaine
prochaine pour la semaine encore après
sa lourde pouces 20 mars
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule merci en
tout cas parce qu'elle soit révélée un
généraliste de vous a été exprimée en
direct sur rt france